he's been in politics since 2005 when
his late father former prime minister
rafiq hariri was assassinated sad hariri
has since been lebanon's leading muslim
sunday politician but the three-time
prime minister is withdrawing from
political life
there is no room for any positive
opportunities for lebanon due to the
iranian influence
our indecisiveness with the
international community internal
divisions and sectarianism
i am suspending work in political life
and so is the future movement and i am
not running in the election nor will the
future movement
the future movement is the largest
sunni-led party in parliament but the
balance of power is against them
he is running against a very strong
syrian
syrian-iranian alliance and a country
and therefore
given that
it seems that the saudis and gulf states
in general are not willing to
pay much of an investment
hariri like his father was once saudi
arabia's man in lebanon but in recent
years that changed so has hariri's
policy towards hezbollah backed by the
predominantly shia iran once
confrontational his critics see him as
too compromising
hariri's exit is a turning point in
lebanese politics the hariris have
dominated the sunni leadership since the
end of the civil war in 1990 but for
many his decision isn't a surprise
hariri's political position weakened in
recent years the former prime minister
himself acknowledged making what he
called mistakes by engaging with foes at
the expense of allies
the sunnis consist of 33 of the
population and this is uh this poses
grave consequences there is no obvious
leader to replace him but it appears
there are efforts to form an
anti-hezbollah alliance
what comes next is that we should have a
large alliance concerning hezbollah
on the politics and
on everything in lebanon even hariri's
allies have criticized the former prime
minister for sharing power with
hezbollah which along with its allies
won the last election
their opponents are hoping to change
that in the upcoming vote in may
some may argue hariri may have been
standing in the way al jazeera beirut